hey guys welcome to the reuben report
i'm still dave rubin i've got desi doyle
and andy reese meyer with me and let's
get right to it baltimore is considering
a curfew for teenagers that's right in a
preliminary vote the city council
approved a bill that could make
baltimore's curfew laws among the
strictest in the country uh basically uh
this started because of a bunch of teens
rampaging through a 7-eleven last year a
lot of vandalizing and stuff like that
uh we've got some details on the curfew
kids under the age of 14 would need to
be home by 9 00 pm year round kids age
14 to 16 would have a curfew of 10 pm on
weeknights during the school year and 11
p.m on weekends there would also be a
daytime curfew during school hours
and more than one citation could result
in a hefty fine
i don't like this i don't like this i
don't think we need the nanny state that
leads then to the police state which
then leads to the militarized state i've
watched a lot of science fiction movies
we've seen this movie before we've seen
this movie before yeah all right just
take it away well that i i agree with
you um i i think this is way overkill
because it's uh taking something that
did happen a real incident which did
frighten people you know there was a
gang of teenagers running around and you
know i don't know exactly how much you
know havoc they wreaked as teenagers do
and we do see these videos popping up
and say it's always in 7-elevens right
for some reason teenagers decide to go
in there and they'd snap up all the slim
jims but you know a curfew isn't
necessarily going to make any difference
on that you have to have a police
officer or other official there to
actually catch them in the act of not
meeting their curfew and then give them
a ticket at the time so all you have to
do is just not let the cops catch you
and then boom curfew is useless it also
seems to me to be overly restrictive you
know you've got kids who have to work
after school you have kids who uh have
to you know have late night um
rehearsals and theater for example you
know you have to i just think it's too
restrictive and it basically punishes
all kids for just a few kids who are um
unable to find something to do with
themselves right 9 p.m should kids be in
bed at night i mean basically you have
to be home playing video games like you
can't even be out in a park right
chasing a ball perhaps yeah what were
you doing at 9pm oh god when i was last
night
for today
uh yeah and like the theater kids are
the ones who are definitely going out
and causing all that happening
you know it sweeps in a lot of kids that
wouldn't necessarily be the ones that
are the ones that are supposed to be
targeted by this yeah my biggest issue i
totally agree is that this is
conditioning these kids at a very young
age to to know that if they or their
peers
step out step out of line then the
government comes in and says you guys
cannot be trusted with freedom you have
to be contained and restrained in your
homes and i think that that really sends
a bad message to somebody who just sort
of grows up and and
gets that idea at a young age that
they're going to be taken control of
yeah i totally agree and that's why the
part about the school day that the
curfew would be uh you know warranted
during the school day
is even worse to me than the night time
thing because playing hooky is like part
of growing up yeah you know what i mean
there's a great episode where uh the
simpsons where bart doesn't go to school
and the whole episode is principal
skinner chasing him around town like
that's a part of growing up and fighting
the system and not being conditioned to
always believe in power so does that
part seem worse maybe than the night
time part to me skip a day of school
yeah i know ferris bueller's fishing
never ever happened in baltimore and
come on that's an iconic film so you
know one of the other parts about it is
that you know they're going to find the
parents and i think that if you are a
parent and you are say working two jobs
and you're not able to be home in the
evenings and so you know obviously
sometimes teenagers are going to go do
impulsive things like run around when
they don't have somebody so it seems
better to not punish the parents who may
not have the resources to ensure that
their teenagers are occupied and
something constructive you know maybe
the city could turn that money instead
over to programs and places for kids to
go you know so you're punishing the
people who already are behind but yeah
you know it would i would generally
guess that you know parents who have to
be at work at night or would not
appreciate you know having to be fined
for something because they don't have
the resources to give their kids
something to do you know there are
policies that show that if you provide
you know basketball courts you know
recreation centers you know places for
kids to go teens to go that are safe
they'll go there yeah i remember growing
up and my dad would always be trying to
get me out of the basement playing video
games with my friends and i always
remember thinking if there was a lit
basketball court at night we would have
been running around but there were no
lit basketball courts kids want to be
outside i think generally yeah and i say
this as a as a big video game i don't
know what pretty thomas edison world you
grew up in where there weren't
basketball courts and i guess that maybe
that's
i grew up on the wrong side of track
apparently i don't know it was pretty
rough but the other side they had the
lit basketball i think the crazy thing
is especially summer is coming up july
4th and what are they going to have to
leave before the fireworks start at 9 00
pm i mean it just seems absurdly
overreaching but the real well i guess
they they could probably be out with
their parents i'm sure there's parties
well but i mean i'm not going to when i
was 15 i wasn't going out to with my
parents to go watch fireworks sorry mom
and dad
i think the real problem obviously is
the kids are acting out this is just
this is not addressing the real issue
here right what we should do is empower
adults with the ability to just beat the
[ __ ] out of these kids if they get out
of line and then because if there's
consequence that's related to the act of
acting out you know and if the police
aren't there you know just be like well
i had to i had to give him a weapon
because uh he was traipsing through the
7-eleven you know i i didn't think that
we were going to go into the into the
pro-beating kids realm which is about
controversy youtube commenters
all about it so playing the devil's
advocate a little bit so i'll give you
the child beating thing is it maybe or
some of this may be okay at the most
local level that if there is a town that
something was really i i personally
don't agree with like the focus level is
that what you yeah just really at the
really micro level if there was a little
town somewhere where just all hell was
breaking loose that the local authority
i guess even though yeah that's probably
an extreme case like you say you know i
could maybe see that happening and some
zombies were around you wouldn't want
the kids out zombies
apocalypse you're definitely going to
need a curfew yeah you know but no i
don't i don't really i don't really see
why they want well i mean actually i
take that back i do see why they would
prefer to put in a curfew because it
actually requires very little from the
city as far as resource it it just means
that the cops get to go find kids to
ticket and then it's a little bit more
source of revenue for the city because
they get to find parents but you know i
can see them not wanting to put the
effort into actually dealing with the
problem and creating a solution to the
problem rather than just you know
putting a band-aid on it wow a solution
to a problem rather than conditioning
kids to think that they're criminals not
the worst idea i've ever heard all right
let's talk about the environment there
were two studies released this week
announcing that a large ice sheet in
west antarctica is beginning to melt
which might start the process of sea
level rising not good
we've got a bit of information for you
so this study from the university of
washington concluded that the collapse
of the thwaites glacier is already
underway this process could be completed
within the next few centuries and would
cause the ocean to rise by nearly two
feet because that glacier is currently
acting as a barrier for the rest of the
ice sheet its collapse could ultimately
trigger a 10 to 13 foot rise in global
sea levels and we've got some info from
a nasa study also the study predicted a
four foot rise in sea levels as the
melting rate accelerates in the amundsen
sea sector winds in the antarctic are
pulling warm water to the surface and
causing the ice to melt global warming
is a contributing factor but not the
sole cause natural non-human induced
changes in climate across the globe
might also be at fault so i wanted to
start with that part and i'm going to go
to our science and green person first so
what they're basically saying here is
that this is a combo of
man-made climate change and that things
are just changing on earth just because
of natural processes is that accepted in
the scientific community at this point
that there's two things happening here
oh yeah i mean it's something where you
know when you get down into the nuance
of these studies they're talking about
um you know there is the natural
processes you know the natural
oscillations that the ocean currents and
the winds go through and global
temperatures you know but there's also
then that human-induced influence that
kicks it up a notch so what that's kind
of what they're doing so you believe in
climate change is that what you're doing
i accept the science of climate change
absolutely
but you know what what i think is most
shocking about this is it's part of it
is your definition of collapse you know
when when the public the general public
hears the word collapse they think oh my
god it's going right now and when
they're talking about it in science
terms in this specific thing with with
glaciers they're talking about you know
there is a point after which it is not
ever going to return that's irreversible
and it will lead to the eventual
collapse you know so there is
scientifically it's more of a slow
collapse obviously it's going to take
you know they estimate about 200 years
or so at the minimum for this specific
glacier the thwaites glacier to uh to
melt and that is going to then be the
issue with the west antarctic ice sheet
which is you know massive yeah it's it
covers half that continent and that's
going to take hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of years but it's still going
to be very important for all coastal
cities am i making this up it's
something like 20 times the size of
manhattan
yeah it's huge i mean when you realize
antarctica is a continent an actual
continent and i forget how big it is in
comparison to say the north american
continent but it is it is darn huge and
it is going to be a problem you know
when uh you know we're not just talking
about this specific glacier being the
only one that's melting it just happens
to be the one that they looked at in
this particular study that's melding
quite quickly we have glaciers melting
all over the world and we have a
greenland ice melt as well so all of
these together cumulatively are going to
raise sea levels as well and there's
really when it's when you get to this
irreversible place you know they're
saying we don't see any way
that these ice sheets are going to be
stopped there's no mountain range
underneath there there's nothing to stop
it so it's part of the problem that this
just happens so slowly as desi is saying
i think that's sort of we deal with
things especially our politicians we
don't deal with issues of today so we
definitely aren't going to deal with
issues of tomorrow so as far as that
it's just happening so slowly that one
day it's just going to keep rising keep
rising keep rising and then we'll just
be swimming and everyone will go oh we
always swam because i don't remember
anybody that didn't swim modern world
will really be more like actual history
yeah at that point um i think that uh
yeah you know
unfortunately maybe the clim for the
climate change uh science
it has been so sort of
hijacked as a political um tool that i
think when people see it even if there
is science behind it or or whatever
they're they're very quick to say uh no
this is definitely just somebody using
it to trump up some kind of agenda and i
think that that's unfortunate because
indeed you know we have seen so much
evidence come out to say that you know
there is a certain point where we are
doing things that are harmful to the to
the the country just just imagine just
cares about everybody else no um to the
world uh however on that note i did look
at some of the sea levels if you look at
los angeles in 100 years if we uh 200
years or so if we have a 10 foot
increase in sea levels the only people
that will be affected are those living
in marina del rey and let's be honest
they'll all be dead by that time
you really wanted to get there with that
yeah
did you see it i could see it coming i
could see it coming is part of this so i
i obviously believe in climate change i
believe these things are happening but
is part of this just sort of what human
evolution is all about like we're gonna
destroy this earth i feel like it's just
sort of the way
evolution is we're gonna stress and then
we're gonna go somewhere else and that's
why we're exploring space because
everyone knows we're gonna do that well
there's a couple different things if i
may first of all i would i would uh
recommend that you say i accept the
science because if you say i believe in
climate change
then it implies a religion and you know
and that's [ __ ] and that's not what
we're talking about we're talking about
you accept the science or you do not
expect i will amend it right now i
accept the science there you go in the
belief phase
but then um when it comes to human
nature i think you are absolutely right
that there is a part of evolution you
know where essentially species and you
know obviously we're the the most
advanced sentient species that's walked
the earth but previously i'm not sold on
that but that's that's a different thing
more sentient let's just say that we can
actually think about what we're doing
unlike you know most uh most species and
what tends to happen in nature is that a
species will expand into its territory
and expand into its range until it uses
up all the resources and you know once
it uses up all the resources nature has
a pretty you know swift and efficient
way of cutting that species back to size
so that it fits within its environment
so we're kind of following along with
that same uh natural progression we do
have the choice though we can at any
time stop that and i think you know
that's the whole point of sciences you
know using science to be able to predict
stuff otherwise why bother yeah do you
think science is having a little bit of
a comeback right now i think cosmos on
fox and you know it's getting some good
buzz there is a sense of like we need to
be a little more scientifically literate
in this country and then stories like
this right i think sort of prove that
don't call it a comeback
i mean i think that science
for whatever reason has like this really
bad rap yeah
which is really strange because
everything we have is based in science
yeah it seems it seems so obvious you
know i mean that goes without saying uh
i certainly hope so you know as a as a
child of science um i i would i would
hope so oh i think it is definitely uh
more popular now than it used to be not
just with cosmos but you know that
facebook i [ __ ] love science yeah
that is people you know i think with csi
the tv show people sort of got
interested in the science science you
know and i think that's that's
popularizing the concept of science it's
popularizing the ideas of the scientific
method and i think with that comes more
engagement from the public although we
know we do have a problem with a very
strong
effort culturally by a certain you know
a group of evangelical right wingers who
insist that you know we have to include
religion in our science classes and you
know we've had to beat back that
particular onslaught periodically since
the 20s so that's the part that i
understand this will be the final
thought on this like the part of these
people that simply don't believe in the
evidence i don't get what their faith
has to do with this why can't you have
faith in
a higher being or whatever your
religious beliefs are and still believe
that humans are doing things give me an
answer to that both of you andy i i
really think that it comes down to
skepticism based on on what i just
talked about earlier which is there
there are people who use it for agenda
um you know point making when
you are on the opposite side of that if
you're a conservative you see man-made
climate change historically being an
issue uh that is sort of um championed
by the left and downplayed by the right
so it's not even about whether or not
it's real or not it's about this is a
this is something that somebody else
says
on on my opposing team so i'm gonna i'm
gonna disagree right it's just about the
endless bipolar nature absolutely let's
tie it to your tribal identity i mean
people have a cultural identity and they
tend to filter the news and any other
information they get through that
cultural identity and so if it doesn't
fit with that cultural identity then
they reject it although i will say there
are evangelical christian scientists you
know there's a climate scientist named
catherine heiho who is doing a great job
of trying to i know
she's the most adorable climate
scientist that has ever existed yet
she's the cutest thing and she also is
able to sort of be an ambassador of
science to these religious groups and
say hey you know you don't have to
believe that the world is more than 6
000 years old in order to understand
physics you know you can say that hey
god created the world he might also have
created physics yeah and so we're just
figuring out how it works so can't we
just get to a place where we can agree
that like we don't know everything
science doesn't explain everything and
religion certainly can't uh do it
andy we cannot get to that place but
we've got to move on
uh a new gallup poll suggests that going
to prestigious colleges
doesn't actually make us any happier in
life or and work
this comes from a survey of 29 000
college graduates by purdue university
and let's look at findings
five in six report doing great in at
least one sphere a sense of purpose
financial security
physical health close relationships or
community pride only 11 are thriving in
all five areas of well-being and the
percentages did not vary based on
whether the grads went to a top 100
school in the u.s news and world report
rankings or one of the bottom 100 so
this is kind of interesting because we
put so much emphasis on going to the
right college no matter how much it
costs and apparently it costs a lot
these days um i went to a new york state
school suny binghamton uh which is a
perfectly fine school pretty good
academic school i smoked a lot of pot
there i learned some stuff i studied
politics so i guess uh something
translated into my life now um does this
surprise you or not surprise you that
going to these better schools isn't
actually equating to any sort of bigger
sense of fulfillment in life it's
surprising to npr
thinks that that
you know academia is the end-all be-all
yeah no it's not surprising to me
because well first of all purdue also is
full of miserable people i'm from
indiana and like that's why you would
probably think that if you're right well
the study went by perdue i think a
little bit of a little tampering might
have gone on there so they would just
try to there's a little shouting that's
right got it um no i didn't go to
college in the traditional sense yeah
meaning i didn't go to college
i went for about a year and a half well
i did not know the prayer did not tell
me that this changes uh
and i got lucky that i am working in an
industry where it doesn't necessarily uh
you don't have to go to college
to work in television um
but you know there's a lot of talking of
talking about things that are important
i know i just discredited my entire self
but you know you can read a lot the
access information is like i went to
college with a lot of kids i hire a lot
of college kids and they're really dumb
they're like drunk they they have the
sheepish mind mentality that like sorry
sorry guys
but uh uh
you know it's it's just i think that
at least to me as i've gotten in my
older my my later 20s i realized that
it's a lot less important about where
you went to school and more about like
what you can actually do on a daily
basis and how like connected you are
with knowledge yeah so what does this
say about our college system because
you'd like to think that if you go to a
good school you will get a good job you
will have more money you will somehow be
happier i think that's sort of the theme
in america that's sort of how it's going
to work and yet we're finding out that i
think it's wonderful i think it's
fabulous i'm glad to hear this because
you know so many of the people that i've
met you know just from just all walks
who are talking who we'll talk about how
oh you know you had to go to a
prestigious university if you wanted to
get into this echelon of society and if
that means that you can still be happy
and still have a fulfilling career and
still do work that you think is
important and satisfac and satisfactory
to you then it's wonderful that you can
go to just a regular old state school
and still be able to achieve those
things you know one of the things that
they don't talk about in this particular
study is about the network that you get
from going to an elite university so i
think that can have a very large impact
on your ability to get a job right out
of graduation and the industry of your
choice but beyond that if it doesn't
make you happier i think that that's
really a boost to everybody who wants to
go to college and then feels like
they're somehow starting off at a
deficit because they didn't go to an
elite university yeah is this also part
of this thing that that colleges people
are talking about this now that colleges
are pricing themselves out of relevance
that people we don't have a great
economy obviously people can't afford to
go to these places anymore and then
they're finding out that college
graduates aren't getting the jobs that
they used to get so is college as like
just a general thing becoming somewhat
obsolete i mean if you ask me
coming from the idea
and the reason i didn't go was because i
had used college as a way to open a
bunch of doors where i could like work
my ass off and then have opportunities
that it happened way sooner than i had
actually planned on that was like for me
you know to work with larry king it was
like i couldn't pass up that opportunity
to have that happen for me so it was
like i probably would have continued to
go to school i just got really lucky and
you know i have the idea that like for
the pursuit of knowledge i would
probably go back someday if this whole
thing goes away so well you know there
are issues with uh you know in some
places like if you needed to get a job
in a in a regular industry not in
entertainment
i mean more like if you need to get a
job in an engineering field then you
must have that if you want to work in
one of these other you know capacities
you must have a degree so knowing that
it's actually possible is is pretty cool
but you know remember there's a student
loan crisis as well and i think that
also negatively impacts people's
happiness and satisfaction later on when
you are i don't know struggling under
crushing debt so you're saying if you
went to a prestigious college and then
you got out of it you were a hundred
thousand dollars in debt it might affect
your
general state of well-being yeah you
might be a little less happy about stuff
you know but there was a good a good
point in that article uh in that
specific study about how good teachers
good teachers and good mentors really
made a big difference in those people
that reported high satisfaction so i
think that that
is a great avenue to to look at you know
how do we get better teachers you know
because if people are satisfied with
their lives 10 20 years on because they
had a teacher who cared about them he
was a really good teacher you know i
think that that shows one a great avenue
for which you know through which we can
create you know better outcomes for
people focusing on the teachers and the
mentoring and sometimes you can get that
teacher in high school it doesn't happen
right from college but good teachers
being being this this launching point
for a good life i think that's really
neat
i like that ending okay let's move on
and talk about weed we're going from
college to weed those
sort of go hand in hand we haven't done
anything on wheat in a couple weeks but
two stories popped up uh in the last
couple days that i thought were really
interesting uh so first off uh the feds
right now are seeking prison time for a
70 year old medical marijuana patient
who was growing weed on his personal
property in washington the state of
washington where medical marijuana is
legal uh they also found they found
about 70 pot plants they also did find
some guns but he wasn't doing anything
illegal per se by the state laws but
again this is the feds that stepped in
and did this because uh medical
marijuana is obviously not uh legal uh
at the federal level um
and i think this is really interesting
because to me i want to start with obama
here because i think he's had this both
ways he makes it seem like he's the cool
hip weed smoking president right and he
talks about weed all the time and even
said about two months ago the thing
about you know weed is no worse than you
know having a couple drinks or something
yet he is in charge of the federal
government if i know anything about
government and he is the one that is
still enforcing these laws that are
allowing the feds to come in and close
these places uh so obama
start start with obama and then we'll go
back so so obviously as president he
can't personally go through every bit of
the government and make sure that
they're doing what he tells them to i
find this very surprising because eric
holder the attorney general put out a
guidance uh what was it six months ago a
year ago saying that we are not going to
focus on individual users we're not
going to focus on uh you know the
non-violent offenders we're going to
focus on people who are obviously
involved in crime and drug trafficking
these people are obviously not involved
in that so i think that there's an issue
right with the so this is with the us
attorney in washington state right so
this is 100 against what eric holder
said by the way the the guy who did this
this 70 year old medical marijuana
patient is facing 10 years in prison as
are
some of his relatives that lived on the
compound and the family friend um so is
this just like the worst kind of
government hypocrisy oh well you know i
love the government so much i have to
you know totally agree with you there no
um
first of all the 10 years is not i don't
think it's normal they're added years
because he was uh found to be interested
in firearms right so you know i don't
know if this is a typical situation
um
i do think this is one of those things
where as as things change
and as uh you know the sovereignty of
states are recognized by the federal
government let's hope
that that um
as you know nationwide mentality towards
this changes and it looks like it's
going in that direction especially for
somebody who's just doing it for
medicinal purposes for for providing for
people who have seizures epilepsy of
cancer yeah i think that
naturally it'll change it's just that
weird space before we get to where we're
going yeah so the medicinal part i want
to get to in a second um but what is the
angle here i really like this is one of
those things where obama says one thing
and does something else and i can't i
just can't figure out what is his what
is the point what is he saying to holder
what that they that they feel this is
appropriate i just don't get it i think
this is a conflict between a u.s
attorney and that is actually defying
orders from the the main office
essentially i you know i don't get the
impression that obama or holder think
that this is a wise use of resources
right so why doesn't holder just get on
the phone i don't know that i don't
understand because you know he could get
on and say you need to stop doing this
this is a waste of resources they're
going after you know a 70 year old man
who owned guns which is you know his
right under the second amendment because
they were saying that he was using those
guns in the commission of a crime
because federally having pot you know
growing wheat on your property is
against the law even though it is not
against the law in the states so it
shouldn't be those things are not even
on the same i know but they are in
conflict and there is a huge gray area
of legal limbo so we know for the u.s
attorney to then sort of defy i i think
there's something else going on with
this particular u.s attorney but i do
not know what that is because really
it's completely illogical for him to be
doing what he's doing yeah all right so
we'll get to the medicinal part in a sec
but shouldn't the republicans to me this
seems like the type of thing where if
they were smart which they're not and we
know that if they were smart they'd be
like this is the type of thing we should
be fighting for because it's fighting
for states rights it's fighting for
individual liberty you get a lot of
sympathy saying i want someone who is
sick to be able to do whatever it takes
to feel better uh why don't they jump on
board this thing uh i think it would
alienate so much of their base as far as
the people who are of the generation who
grew up with like those crazy videos in
the 1960s of kids like smoking weed and
ended up in like flop houses and yeah
right
i think that's the only reason but i
agree with you i mean look this is an
opportunity for you to like be on the
cutting edge of of like the future so
why wouldn't you take it and they could
be taking they could be taking a
populist thing and saying look what
obama is doing that's why i don't get
the obama angle and i don't get the the
republican angle
i think it like i think you're right i
think it has to do with the preconceived
notions from the base from you know the
uh
older generations who are less likely to
be open to the idea of medical marijuana
or even recreational marijuana although
but let's be real like my parents i'm
sure smoked way more weed than i ever
did yeah well that's because you didn't
go to college i didn't go to college
right you're right and you know when you
don't go to school the drugs are just
you can't find them exactly it's not
there all right so this brings me to the
medicinal marijuana portion of this
which i also want to talk about and this
one even seems worse than the previous
weed story
patients who are using medicinal
marijuana for pain and other chronic
symptoms are getting turned down by
insurers right now even in states where
medicinal marijuana is legal uh insurers
are basically reluctant to cover it
because of conflicting laws because as
far as the fda is concerned because it's
the federal drug administration
medicinal marijuana is not legal so now
we have people with cancer and aids and
all kinds of other drugs that are do
finding something that is helping them
and helping them deal with pain and now
again we have the federal government
coming in and stopping the insurers from
allowing these people to medicate
themselves is this to me it is like the
worst of the horse well i got the
impression that it was the insurance
companies choosing not to
well it is but it's because it's under
the window yeah and because of that
legal limbo it's understandable that a
big company would not want to step in
the middle of that until it's actually
figured out whether or not you know they
are assisting in the commission of a
crime by covering it with insurance uh
versus not
thank you for cleaning that up but what
i would say is you know duh insurance
companies never really do want to add
coverage for things that means they have
to pay out more money they're not
interested in that so i can see them
also saying oh we'll just wait because
you know that means that we have to put
out more money for something and we're
not going to do that if we don't have to
right so like everything does this just
come down to money because to me the fda
loves everything in pill form and when
you have everything in pill form there's
also three minutes of diarrhea and
possible suicide and death and all that
other stuff that comes with every one of
those commercials you know all the
people dancing and they're happy but
they're also having diarrhea and death
and all that kind of stuff yes uh and
thought to suicide they were inevitable
anyway yeah so is this partially because
marijuana just doesn't have it's we
don't have a pill yet we don't have just
that perfect pill and also that when
they when it comes out one day which it
will it's not going to have all those
side effects because weed doesn't have
those side effects so is this just like
a failure of our system at the highest
level side effects i don't know i mean
it just depends on who you talk to
you get paranoid or whatever but you
know how much you use you know for sure
i've never been with anyone who's
smoking weed and suddenly had horrible
diarrhea there we go you were lucky sir
let me tell you i've been around some
good wheat people um yeah in indiana our
weed isn't that good yeah you don't know
what's going to happen usually that's
laced with some kind of like you know
benzodiazepine or something [ __ ]
so which the fda is totally for oh
yeah exactly there's something that
starts with benzo that the fda is forced
yes yeah close it up uh
ben's oil it's a it's car oil motor oil
um
well okay yes it is money and it does
come down to money was that your
question i don't even remember yeah but
who's spending a thousand dollars a
month on weed like people who are very
sick so yeah if you're very sick you
could i know i saw this and i thought
the same thing in that in that sense
like i know a guy who can cut that in
half for you
because you can he'll give you as much
as you ever want but like that seems
like a very
large amount even to the point if you
were trying to medicate every day yeah
i don't want to get caught in the
semantics
you know but let's talk about you know
if you are somebody who is truly
disabled by some kind of condition that
makes it so you can't work then yeah
you're going to be on disability which
pays very little and then the only
medication that gives you any relief is
something that's not covered i mean i
can understand it does put people who
are poor because of their disability
into a huge bind you know i don't know i
don't know how we solve that particular
problem because personally i'm not sure
it's a good idea to get the fda involved
in studying and testing and approving
marijuana because we've seen what they
do with the pharmaceutical industry and
we see i i just i just right
so where do you see that going
i really don't know because if they do i
see it turning into pill form i see it
you know losing its effectiveness i see
it being a controlled market and that
means that big pharmaceuticals will uh
companies will take over and then it
kind of ruins it for everybody because
we've seen what happens with everything
when the suits get involved right so
okay so i'm on board that so then what
do we do related to insurance then so
then that's the best you know maybe
there's a way for the uh for the federal
government to end the legal limbo aspect
and say okay if you're in a state that
has decided to allow for recreational or
medical marijuana if you're in a state
that does that then we are not going to
prosecute you and give insurance
companies direct and specific legal
guidance that they can offer that
without themselves getting into some
kind of uh you know accessory related
crime right which going back to the
previous story that seems to be in line
with the thinking of what obama and
holders should be doing why don't they
do it they just don't seem to be doing
it so so uh go ahead no i just think
that as far as the drug companies go
though those who need to be the people
who step up and make an actually
effective product because for all of the
people who are selling a lot of other
[ __ ] yeah but you know it's another
opportunity for them to do something
right they're not all horrible i mean
they make a lot of really good things
that help a lot of really
sick people you know and i think that
they they obviously wouldn't exist if
they were killing everybody with
diarrhea and
nausea all the time and i i just wanna
you know i think that as we go forward
with this as things change it'll it'll
obviously you know like i said before
it's just something that's sort of
caught in this weird gray area right now
yeah we're working through i think these
issues what i think one thing that could
be done is when people uh make sure that
they tell the representatives at the
local state and national level we want
to make this legal and we want to end
this legal limbo and congress has the
power to do that more so i think than uh
obama with executive actions he can only
do so much but if it's if it's built
into the law
you know if we demand that of our
representatives you know it it there is
a possibility that it could happen so to
get us to get us to demand that do we
need like a george clooney to jump on
board the weed thing publicly instead of
it seems like we talk about weed and
everyone you go to the easy jokes i get
it you know we talk we could go to snoop
dogg and willie nelson but do we meet
and woody house and do we need someone
like a clooney to
to literally get sick and then be like
this is how i'm helping myself and that
that would be the thing that would get
people
to realize how screwed up this system is
i think that would help you know i don't
know i'm not wishing sickness on yours
no no no but uh having having you look
at me like oh lord like you you're like
just you're probably i was not that was
not a shot at you i wasn't thinking
about nothing but health i don't think
he has to get sick i would prefer it not
that way that it's somebody who
basically says this is a this is a civil
libertarian issue and we can all
basically say get the government out of
this particular out of our lives in this
particular area you know and just move
forward with that you know maybe having
a famous spokesperson a celebrity
spokesperson would would be the trick to
help galvanize people to uh to tell the
representatives but
you know it's it's taken a long time to
even get to the point where we are now
where we have bring us all mandy
yeah i no i i don't know there you go
you don't want to besmirch the good name
of yours no
just i think that i i think celebrities
doing things that are political i hate
so much anyway that it's like it's just
it's an eye roller for me as you know
somebody who doesn't watch tmz every
single day right so i don't know so it
would be ineffective for me but i my
mind's already made up so maybe i'm not
a really good person to ask all right
well my well wishes are with george
clooney and let's move on
uh this is fascinating there is new data
from spotify showing just how badly our
attention span is crumbling you might
have stopped watching this already i'm
only six seconds in i think uh they have
shown that people are skipping songs to
the point of addiction to it let's look
at the research findings nearly a
quarter of all songs on spotify get
skipped within five seconds of starting
that's basically 25 a quarter i'm not a
math magician but i can do that uh more
than a third are skipped within 30
seconds nearly half of all songs are
skipped at some point so even if you
loved your who's popular with the kids
the beyonce you're still skipping her
and uh teens show the most inclination
to skip but there's an increase for
those in their mid-40s as well
i guess none of this should be
surprising right we're all doing this
all day long with our fonts and we're
all tweeting and i again i admit that
i'm on this stuff all the time um but
there's something i thought interesting
that it's related to music now too like
even music
uh we're losing our attention and our
ability fragmented attention i find that
to be the case and i and actually as you
sent as i was reading this story i
realized i had a video playing in the
background that i was supposed to also
be listening to but then i got bored and
so i went over and checked something
else and i went oh my gosh i'm doing it
right now yeah yeah so were you tweeting
while i was reading that i was looking i
was looking away were you tweeting or
facebooking there's a different app
involved there but yes no uh
yeah but
i think just given the opportunity to
change what's happening we're going to
take it right i mean how many times did
you listen to the radio when a
nickelback song came on you were like
jesus exactly
through these you know i would have
skipped it before five seconds was up
and i think if you have your playlist
set up you know and you've got songs
that you you know select to listen to
maybe you just don't feel like listening
to it right then maybe you'll come back
to it and i don't know if it's
necessarily an example or a
reason to say like we're just so crazy
and out of control it's like we're ex
we're doing what we what the whole point
of the thing is it's like to give you
choice and you're using you're
exercising your choice yeah so i'm glad
you went there immediately because i do
agree with that as a basic principle
that maybe this is just the next step in
this we seem to think everything's bad
you know everything's getting faster and
shorter and whatever but i do think
there's a chance that maybe we're
sort of we're allowing our brains to
work on other things because you don't
because this short term thing you can do
five things at once you can now watch a
video and you could probably mute that
video and have music on and be tweeting
and and we're doing maybe we are rewi
we've talked about the rewiring of our
brains and maybe we are rewiring in a
good way is that possible oh i think
absolutely you know we're our brains our
brains are as humans we are so adaptable
and our brains are adapting to this new
reality that we've created for ourselves
and you know maybe the reason why we're
switching is because we really couldn't
before before you were limited to what
was playing on the radio right then and
whatever you could switch to that might
be interesting or your cassette tapes
you know so we had the fact that we're
actually in a place now where we can
choose for ourselves and have this wide
menu to choose from on our own maybe
that's what our brains naturally always
wanted to do yeah we couldn't because
the you know the media didn't allow us
to yeah
yeah well i think you're right about the
radio thing because this past weekend i
was driving up to davis it's from l.a
it's about a six hour drive and i was
doing the the radio thing just fm radio
and i realized how quickly you i don't
even know if it was five seconds that i
could hear a song and immediately switch
so maybe this isn't that new well
there's a lot more garbage music out
there first of all
for real yeah because i used to work in
music i was in a band you know it's a
lot easier to make music now it's a lot
easier to get your music on spotify you
just have to basically pay 49 bucks and
it shows up there so it's like oh that's
interesting so just you just think
there's more garbage in there absolutely
the level of uh you know the barriers to
entry have come down so much with the
advent of technology and recording
technology specifically that more people
are able to make more things if you
search for a song that you like on
spotify you know let's use uh your
favorite beyonce like you're just
talking yes you will find the beyonce i
like tina turner more but i was trying
to wow well um
anyway uh
if you find beyonce now i'm off my track
thanks to tina turner you know riding on
the freeway not not me uh if you look at
that beyonce song there's gonna be four
different cover versions of that by like
local bands from idaho you know and and
they're not very good sorry so of course
you're gonna see right so we've just
made the pool bigger and bigger
i wonder how much we can extrapolate
from this particular setting you know
great that they have all these metrics
that spotify that they can actually look
and say oh my god look when they they
they peak at this time of the day
indeed you know and but as far as how
much we can extrapolate from that the
actual fragmentation of attention spans
from people i think spotify is very
specific because you know it is more
hands-on than just turning on something
like pandora in the background and just
letting it choose for you that
randomization so if it's more hands-on
then it's going to show more people are
going to have more fragmented attention
because it requires you to do that for
the most part but you know i don't know
that that means that that is necessarily
one a bad thing and two that it's
happening really as much as this specif
specific study would in indicate it may
not be that it's like that as much for
everybody it may just be that that's
because that's how spotify works best
yeah so i like that we're being pro
attention and anti-attention here we're
giving it we're giving it both sides but
then i was thinking you know could we
ever have a classical music comeback
where you know what i mean where you
really listen to one piece for 20
minutes or could could a bohemian
rhapsody even ever be written now you
know because we're so in this
katy perry churned out as you said you
know like you now have these
when all these pop songs come out
there's literally teams of like 40
people just coming up with some stupid
repetitive beat uh could we ever have
sort of long form music actually come
back or is that really a thing of the
past i think the nature of how the music
business works today you know figuring
out what the formula is to have a
popular song you're talking the
difference between commercially popular
versus artistic so as long as artists
have an opportunity to get their music
and their work out to a wider audience
you know we don't have the same system
that we used to for classical music um
you know if they're able to still get it
out there then i think yeah that we will
still have a resurgence or or the the
survival of classical music in longer
form pieces i think so that's a big
question
yeah well the good thing about having
more opportunities to get more music out
is that then as fan bases go they're
able to be segmented more so if you're
just into that one thing you can go and
find that the formulaic process of the
music industry has been going on since i
don't know 1950 i'm sure i mean it's
like you know you look at a pop song
then you look at a pop song now you've
got chord progressions you've got beats
that are very much the same you're just
recycled over and over but if you're a
consumer you are no longer just getting
your music from the mtvs or
the radio you know you can go out and if
you would like to listen to uh a cool
train record go for it you know do it or
the new version of a coltrane record or
whatever that is tina turner in your
case yeah well i wonder how many of you
actually watched this entire video that
would be i guess the ultimate lesson in
this uh would be that so let us know in
the comments down below and we've got
one more for you let's talk about robot
sex we talk a lot about robots we talk a
lot about sex so i really thought this
story would be uh pretty perfect
a new survey found that one in five
people in the uk
would be willing to have sex with a
robot uh 2 000 people were quizzed on
their attitudes towards androids and 46
surveyed admitted that they'd either
have sex with a robot or not judge
others who chose to have robot sex
um
to me this is just the way things are
going yes people will start having sex
with robots in the not too distant
future and they're probably partly doing
it already in the online thing and all
that um
would you have sex with a robot does he
do him you know i i guess it would
depend on the robot i really can't
imagine
so if it was a genuine law robot from ai
remember that remember that yeah i was
like oh okay well that makes sense in
the context of ai where people are not
allowed to reproduce anymore because the
earth is too small and can't sustain
them so that way
that's kind of what it's that was one of
the parts of why it was everything went
on for my entire childhood i know
so you know the idea of that it makes
sense in a logical sort of uh science
fiction i like how you took this
immediately to the intellectual part
would you have sex with a robot desi i
you know i don't know like i said it
would depend on the robot they're
already doing this in japan i mean
they're already if you ever happen to
stumble upon any of the sex conventions
from japan the photos from those are
quite insane and interesting and you're
like wow okay as long as you already
have the money for that then you can buy
your own and it's already happening now
yeah so there is a movement in japan
called otaku which uh is a movement for
the rising number of men that are opting
for relationships with virtual women so
they're that's not necessarily a robot
that's just a virtual but you can see it
going to that that place it's the next
step before the before the jude law
thing is that sex with robots andy no
how do you feel about it no um because
well we're so far off from jude law
robots exactly if you look at these
people or these people like look i'm
already doing it yes you see yeah if you
look at these robots these androids like
they are terrifying first of all yeah
second of all dweebcast
my show yeah
the number one rule the number one
prevailing rule is the light just like
freaked me out yeah the robots yeah they
know the number one rule is that they
will they will kill us and and so if you
start submitting to them in the bedroom
they are going to be able to be much
more persuasive uh when the apocalypse
doesn't if
if it comes it will come so you're uh
all right so we'll just move to that for
a second you believe the robots will
take over one day no i mean
yes yes yes so so the sex would just be
dangerous because it'll facilitate it
happening faster i think so yeah the
general idea here well i had another
idea that came up when i was reading it
was oh wait a second that kind of makes
sense not just in this in the context of
the otaku in japan that you're talking
about but also what about say a country
like china where a one-child policy has
resulted in a huge gender imbalance you
know where there are more men and there
aren't enough women for them to get
married to so you've got a whole
generation or more of men who have no
outlet for that so when you got angry
horny men what happens well you get wars
and stuff so
maybe this is a robot that was the first
commercial you just did it never know
yep
[ __ ] a robot forward you know
make cyber not war yeah is that a good
tagline like cyber love something yeah
it's there um well then of course this
will lead to ultimately robots having
sex with robots and then whatever babies
what about same-sex what about same-sex
robots i mean it's all gonna be there
what about uh robot human marriage they
they did an episode of futurama about
robosexual marriage which was pretty
perfect but i mean if we go if you just
extrapolate this that i mean someone
will fall in love with their robot
there's a guy somewhere i think in the
uk that's trying to marry his computer
right now because he loves it so much
and you know blah blah blah so i mean is
that crazy to be thinking about all this
stuff uh you know i don't think it's
crazy to be thinking about it might be
premature but eventually i think we will
probably have to discuss and figure out
the ethics of all of this i mean i know
it does what about premature robo
ejaculation
is it is it right you know
you know is there an ethical issue with
you know with relationships you know
what if people abandon their
relationships in order to have a robot a
robot that never complains and never
asks you to hey do the dishes you know
and stuff like that if you let a robot's
battery die is that like neglectful
hummus is it killing it like i wonder
yeah i mean
what i'm still trying to figure out is
where we reach the difference between
like a flashlight you know and a blow up
doll and then an actual android robot
you know is that is this like that's the
gateway drug right to robo well that's
why i'm saying this is all happening so
you have the
the fleshlight which is basically a
piece of plastic that you can whack off
with what was the second thing you said
the
the dog then the blow well we had blow
up dials back in the so this is all just
natural progression and doesn't sex and
porn just sort of lead the way i mean
that it's changed video right from from
beta or master beta to uh
vhs so good you know
to digital video so like sex just kind
of leads the way and we just follow
right yeah it does seem to be the thing
that that folks focus on mostly when
they're working on technology it's like
oh let's not figure out a better way to
i don't know feed the world let's
instead figure out how to have better
sex you know that's that's the driver of
much of the technology unfortunately i
don't i don't understand why uh why
we're so surprised by this or anything
you know i mean this does seem like the
natural progression i do think it's
weird you know yeah i don't know that
i'm gonna find myself in a robo parlor
anytime soon you know usually the people
that are against robot sex are the ones
secretly having it at home you know i
mean meeting in an airport bathroom to
have robot sex maybe by the time that we
have to address the robot sexual
relationships um
or the robosexuals as they call them we
will at that point be uh
letting dogs get married and to people
and cats and so by that time it won't be
a big deal all right well on that note
i'm dave rubin and i'm pro robot sex i
want to thank desi doyan andy reese
meyer their twitterers are right down
below and barring a robot revolution we
will do it again next week
you